three things I would never do in my body
care number one I would never use a
loofer I literally get a jump scare they
really harb a germs even if you wash
them regularly they're still sitting in
a damp environment and they can grow
mold I would use a silicone mint instead
because those just don't Harbor bacteria
microbes in the same way number two I
would never use an aluminium free
deodorant they just don't work aluminum
is good it works and number three I
would never spray my perfume on the neck
and deck area the reason for that is a
lot of the time some of the fragrant
ingredients in the perfume are like
phototoxic which means they're fine they
just can make your skin irritated
especially if they get sun I always
spray my fragrance on the back of my
neck under my hairline and that means it
lasts longer and you kind of get the
scent of it when you move and swish your
hair around